So I've got two parallel lines.
So that's the first
line right over there
and then the second
line right over here.
Let me denote that
these are parallel.
These are parallel lines.
Actually, I can do that
a little bit neater.
And let me draw a transversal,
so a line that intersects both
of these parallel lines,
so something like that.
And now let's say
that we are told
that this angle right
over here is 9x plus 88.
And this is in degrees.
And we're also told that
this angle right over here
is 6x plus 182, once
again, in degrees.
So my goal here and my question
for you is, can we figure out
what these angles
actually are, given
that these are parallel lines
and this is a transversal line?
And I encourage you
to pause this video
to try this on your own.
Well, the key here to realize
is that these right over here
are related by the
fact that they're
formed from a transversal
intersecting parallel lines.
And we know, for example,
that this angle corresponds
to this angle right over here.
They're going to be
congruent angles.
And so this is 6x plus 182.
This is also going
to be 6x plus 182.
And then that helps us
realize that this blue angle
and this orange
angle are actually
going to be supplementary.
They're going to add up to 180
degrees, because put together,
when you make them
adjacent, their outer rays
form a line right over here.
So we know that 6x plus
182 plus 9x plus 88
is going to be equal
to 180 degrees.
And now we just have
to simplify this thing.
So 6x plus 9x is
going to give us 15x.
And then we have 182 plus 88.
Let's see, 182 plus 8,
would get us to 190.
And then we add another 80.
It gets us to 270-- plus
270-- is equal to 180.
If we subtract 270
from both sides,
we get 15x is equal
to negative 90.
And now we can divide
both sides by 15.
And we get x is equal
to-- what is this?
Let's see, 6 times 15
is 60 plus 30 is 90.
So x is going to be
equal to negative 6.
So far, we've made
a lot of progress.
We figured out what x is equal
to. x is equal to negative 6,
but we still haven't figured out
what these angles are equal to.
So this angle right
over here, 9x plus 88,
this is going to be equal to
9 times negative 6 plus 88.
9 times negative
6 is negative 54.
Let me write this down
before I make a mistake.
Negative 54 plus
88 is going to be--
let's see, to go from 88 minus
54 will give us 34 degrees.
So this is equal to 34,
and it's in degrees.
So this orange angle
right here is 34 degrees.
The blue angle is going
to be 180 minus that.
But we can verify that by
actually evaluating 6x plus
182.
So this is going to be
equal to 6 times negative 6
is negative 36 plus 182.
So this is going to
be equal to-- let's
see, if I subtract the
6 first, I get to 176.
So this gets us to 146 degrees.
And you can verify-- 146 plus
34 is equal to 180 degrees.
Now, we could also figure out
the other angles from this
as well.
We know that if
this is 34 degrees,
then this must be
34 degrees as well.
Those are opposite angles.
This angle also
corresponds to this angle
so it must also be
34 degrees, which
is opposite to this angle,
which is going to be 34 degrees.
Similarly, if this one right
over here is 146 degrees,
we already know that this
one is going to be 146.
This one's going to be
146 since it's opposite.
And that's going to be
146 degrees as well.